hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen heute zu einem neuen video
ritschel ist wieder auf meinem bett hier
und quatschen was in die kamera und
wahrscheinlich schon am titel dass da
irgendwie was ein bisschen komisch ist
und darüber wollte ich heute mit euch
reden sind zeitung wo ich das video
gerade aufnehme ist der einundzwanzigste
august also der sonntag es als video day
sind gerade vorbei die gamescom ist
jetzt glaube ich auch jeden moment
vorbei und ich wahrheit vom zweiten
august bis zum 16
august im urlaub an der nordsee zusammen
mit meiner familie unter anderem halt
auch max grafschafter und sebastian es
geht sorgt und es ist mittlerweile bei
mir wirklich der fall geworden dass ich
nicht irgendwohin fahren kann ohne dass
michael leute erkennen oder dass ich
nicht vor die tür gehen kann oder dass
wirte fotos möchten oder dass die
innenstadt gehe ohne dass leute
irgendwie mich ansprechen mit mir reden
möchten und mich irgendwie erkennen oder
so und die dürfte das wirklich nicht
falsch verstehen also ich habe da
wirklich überhaupt nichts gegen aber
manchmal geht es wirklich zu weit
und das war im urlaub der fall hier sind
am 16 august um 9 uhr 30 zurückgefahren
das heißt musste relativ frühe aufstehen
weil ich halt noch am abend irgendwie
auch so ein paar events ihr musste auf
seine youtube sache und so weiter und so
fort das heißt die letzten beiden
richtigen urlaub sonnentage die ich an
der nordsee hatte waren der 14 15 august
und da war halt am strand jeweils zu den
kompletten tag da ich habe dir doch mal
video gesehen wo ich einen tage meinem
urlaub euch gezeigt habe wenn ich
verlinke ich euch das mal hier also da
könnt ihr sehen wie so ein typischer tag
in meinem urlaub aussage jedenfalls bin
ich dann an dem 16
august nach hause gegangen irgendwann
nach dem strand zu gegen 18 uhr und der
plan war dann halt wieder an uns
abduschen und irgendwie uns dann noch
mal mit freunden treffen und zu den
letzten abend genießen um dann am
nächsten tag morgens abzureisen und als
ich dann halt am frühen arm nach hause
kam habe ich von der kürzung brief
entdeckt bissinger umschlag wo das hier
drauf stand ein kontrast luca oder
irgendwie so vor allem wie kann man sich
so beschissen verschreiben alter da
steht dafür der strich sein kontrakt
jährigen die komplett verpackt und luca
irgendwie mit einem
wart ihr besoffen
ich habe mir dann auf jeden fall diesen
teilgenommen den ganzen brief
aufgeklappt und ich lese ich jetzt mal
vor was da drin stand weil der ab mai
wieder ein zuschauer hat wieder in
diesem brief geschrieben den vor meiner
haustür gelegt weil darin geschrieben
heil luca wir waren gerade hier und
wollten eigentlich zu dir aber war es
nicht da deswegen wollen wir morgen
nochmal wiederkommen so gegen 16 uhr wie
kommen lg und jetzt sie sich mal den
ganzen rechtschreibfehlern vor heiko
luca wir waren gerade hier
großgeschrieben und wollten eigentlich
mit d und e irgendwie mittendrin es mit
dir alter für dir aber du warst nicht da
punkt deswegen wollen wir morgen nochmal
wiederkommen drei aussetzer drei
ausrufezeichen
deswegen wollen wir morgen nochmal
wiederkommen zu gegen 16 uhr wied kommen
ihr könnt ihr euch hier nochmal komplett
durchlesen wenn ihr da gerade bock drauf
habt ja ist denn aber darum soll es ja
gar nicht gehen sondern einfach um die
messe die dahinter so ein bisschen
verständnis und zwar dann wirklich wenn
man sich das mal so auf einer anderen
ebene betrachtet da waren leute haben
wir herausgefunden wo ich im urlaub
wohne sind dahin gegangen um 16 uhr
anschein habe mir einen brief vor die
tür gelegt weil ich wohl nicht
aufgemacht habe bis zu dem zeitpunkt am
strand und haben dann einfach mal so
richtig 30 gesagt hey wir waren hier du
warst nicht da sein mal bitte morgen um
16 uhr noch mal hier dann sehen wir dich
dann wollte mich komplett verarschen ich
mein länder wenigstens so was drin
stehen würde von wegen hey sorry falls
du deine privatsphäre stören wir wissen
du wohnst und vielleicht ist es deine
urlaub aber wir wollten einfach mal
fragen ob ihr ein foto mit ihm machen
können weil wir auch morgen abreisen und
wir wollten dich nochmal treffen dass
uns einzige chance es tut uns leid falls
die steuer dass wir so stocker wer sich
unterwegs sind und eine wohnung
ausfindig gemacht haben
aber hey hast du vielleicht ein foto
wird uns machen aber nein die waren
einfach nur komplett unhöflich in dem
brief ich meine vielleicht einfach nicht
was dazu sagen soll also natürlich
werden jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder
irgendwelche leute den kommentaren von
euch an kommen die einfach so gutherzig
die menschen sind meine mutter zum
beispiel auch ein mensch meine mutter
hat mir hat auch gesagt so hey luca wenn
man diese böse bei den briten
irgendwelche zuschauer von dir doch mal
froh dass ich sofort natürlich das bin
ich ja auch aber ich finde so support
geht bis hierhin und ab da ist es
einfach nur noch zu viel ich weiß nicht
ob ihr versteht was ich meine aber ich
finde es so ultra cool wenn leute mich
ihnen auf der straße ansprechen oder
wenn ihr ein foto mit mir machen wollen
oder einfach korrekt sind oder fanpages
für mich auch instagram machen oder mir
voll gold videos gucken aber ab dem
zeitpunkt wo sache kommen die finden
meine wohnung ausschreiben ihrem brief
schicken den mir laufen mir daher
verfolgen mich stalker mäßig ab da als
ob hier oder ab hier da geht es
definitiv zu weit das ist eine ganz neue
liga das ist da kann ich nicht mehr
lächeln bei das war halt die eine sache
die ich sagen wollte dass ich einfach
diesen brief bekommen habe so stocker
mäßig die leute raus wo ich wohne
schreiten wir ein brief und inter so
unhöflich und sagen komm morgen 16 uhr
wieder hierhin die andere sache ist
jetzt gerade in verbindung mit dem video
der sbz der gamescom war es ja gerade
sonntag und die letzten beiden tage
waren video der ist gerade verletzt hat
von der gamescom habe ich glaub ich zu
beginn des videos sogar schon gesagt wir
waren auf jeden fall gestern nach dem
video days am rudolfplatz in köln und da
war irgendwie so eingängig kommen
konzert oder irgendwie ich weiß gar
nicht ob das der rudolfplatz war
jedenfalls haben wir uns da irgend etwas
zu essen holen und dann auch noch
verwandte von max und sebastian
getroffen sie sind ja brüder und werbung
auf die tante da getroffen und da müssen
wir den unterhalten und ich wurde vorher
schon von ihm so einen 35-jährigen typ
mehr cars at work die hand gegeben eine
sehr coole zu treffen
so braucht der gamescom ich sehe keine
haare räumlich bei der gamescom bilder
so letztendlich bedeute nicht bei der
games kommen aber anderes thema oder
deshalb weg gegangen in solln
nebenstraße rainer wir dachten uns ja ok
haushalt nicht mehr bei gedacht
bedachten tätigen wieder ein zuschauer
oder ein vater von dem zuschauer oder
kennt mich halt irgendwie dann haben wir
den verwandten von wachstums apple
getroffen und auf einmal meinte max
lukaku hinter mir da steht so drei meter
weiter entfernt wieder dieser typ dieser
35-jährige so komplett alleine und kurz
auf die bühne steht also und guckt so ab
und zu mal so rüber zu uns so guckt
damit unterfordert sowie darüber wieder
nach vorne wir dachten einfach dann nur
so ok der ist wohin wirklich eine
komplett andere richtung gegangen hat er
uns jetzt irgendwie verfolgt so und dann
haben wir alles gesagt zu den verwandten
von max und seppel und sind dann halt
auf dem weg zu mir gegenüber so eine
ampel gegangen oder noch einmal an der
ampel steht dann wieder leben und so
geht mit uns über die ampel
da dachten wir uns auch so dick aktions
verarschen ich weiß das ist überhaupt
nicht böse gemeint gegen die typen
vielleicht verwirklicht so dass er
einfach sich verlaufen hat und dann
zufällig genau neben und stand bei dem
konzert und dann zufällig auch über die
ampel muss oder so das kann ja alles
sein allerdings habe ich mich in dem
moment auch wieder so gefühlt von wegen
so ist es jetzt einen stalker will er
uns verfolgen will jetzt rausfinden wo
ich wohne und nach diesen beiden sachen
also einerseits mit dem brief und jetzt
dieser person da wo wir alle 34 so ein
bisschen alles hatten dass der jetzt
irgendwie verfolgt oder soll ich mir
gedacht mach jetzt einfach mal wieder
über die privatsphäre also ich wollte
jetzt gar nicht mehr so viel darüber
lagern das waren jetzt quasi beiden
story aber einfach mal freude dass man
sich so selber so ein bisschen einen
kopf fasst und sich fragen muss ich
wirklich so weit gehen nur um diese
personen zu treffen mit ihr zu reden
oder mit ihrem foto zu machen oder
irgendwas anderes zu tun vielleicht mal
einfach so ein bisschen weiter
nachdenken und sich fragen ob ihr
dasselbe haben wollen würde dass ihnen
die andere leute warum haus stehen oder
dass ihr verfolgt werden oder irgendwie
so etwas in die richtung das war einfach
wichtig heute mal darüber zu reden weil
ich jetzt halt bekommen hat und diese
andere sache da in der innenstadt in
köln da der fall war deswegen dachte ich
zocke da heute einfach mal drüber
vielleicht ist die message so ein
bisschen angekommen das war's mit dem
video meine damen und herren ich auch
heute hat es gefallen wenn es das getan
hat will ich nicht
meine bewertungen freuen schreibt mir
noch mal die kommentare was ihr davon
haltet sonst geht morgen oder übermorgen
noch ein video von mir über die videos
kommen weil ich ja dort auf der bühne
war und ein paar fanpages von mir haben
mich ja dafür gerettet weil ich nicht so
viel zeit in das programm investiert
habe das kann ich euch aber alles
erklären dazu aber mehr in den nächsten
video und jetzt haut rein leben ist gut
soll ich mit meiner musik machen ich
weiß nicht irgendwie wahlerfolg viele
leute werden wieder der sie es gemacht
haben und gab es auch beim bock drauf
also schreibe für die kommentare